but we're standing on one of the most
famous streets in America Worth Avenue
which needs no address on Worth Avenue
you find some of the most exclusive
shops and in this case art galleries in
America we're standing outside of our
catcher gallery one of the most famous
galleries on this street that shows a
variety of great blue-chip artists from
rauschenberg there's a de Kooning in
their condo you name it Chamberlin but
tonight is an important event because
they are showing Kevin O'Leary's
photographic images Kevin for many
people better known as mr. wonderful one
of the Shark Tank TV stars has had a
great passion for photography all of his
life and in this show he's showing some
of his favorite photographs that are on
the wall to support the benefit for the
teenage entrepreneurs and the Perry
Cohen foundation so it's going to be a
great night
and lots of exciting people here and a
very exciting show and we're going to
take a look at it I could have a good
afternoon we're delighted to have you
here or richer gallery I'm so happy it's
such an honor this is such a legendary
gallery and it's on Worth Avenue one of
those famous believe me for any artist
it's very cool it's very cool we are
also honored that the proceeds of this
show through our culture are going to
support the Perry Cohen foundation and
the teenage entrepreneur association
that you put together that's my primary
motivation in doing this is you know I
met Nick and Pamela I heard the story
the story is tragic but it doesn't mean
that it can't bring something good to
others and so we're trying to keep his
name alive this way I'm supporting this
initiative because it's right on mandate
for what I want to do in charity and I'm
glad that my work can be sold for it it
was a great kid I never met him but all
the people I've talked to that have met
him said he was just a you know a bundle
of life that wanted to get out there and
do stuff and that's the definition of an
entrepreneur so that's all right we love
the entrepreneurial spirit you know he
was washing cars when he was 6 or 7
years of age I love that story
and he was a shark tank fan as well
yeah well that's their really touching
this is all very poetic and appropriate
it is it's a lot of Shark Tank fans
there's a lot of Perry's out there
it keeps his name out there and it also
supports others that want to be like him
and so that's great I mean I can't wait
to make this as big as it can be and I
love to show my work there's always a
question you look at this image you say
to set yourself
what's wrong with this what what is why
is it bothering me what is about this
that I have to learn more and I love
images like that they become immortal
because people keep looking at them I
noticed in the window of the picture of
the lifeguard yes and then I looked a
second time and I said wait a minute
they're four legs and there's one body
that's really so that's part of the code
it was the moment on the beach it was
the motivation then Tucket when he bent
over to bite into a sandwich and I was
right behind him I looked up and I said
magic moment and it's a very naughty
picture because it confuses people and
it's got a lot of intrigue to it and I
think that's great I think is - we're
gonna go over to the next room here yeah
these series of aircraft is just a
happen chance freak accident that
occurred - - negative film that got
stuck in a camera for a decade and
basically grew mold and when I found the
body a decade later I immediately
processed the film I found in it and
when the lab called me back they said
Kevin you've got to come over here I
have never seen anything like this and
what had happened is the mold which is
it which is organic when it was fixed in
the chemicals obviously stopped growing
and froze like crystals each one is
unique based on how the nitrate worked
with the mold and they are just theories
like from another world the
compositional elements also have a kind
of hybrid of a kind of abstract
expressionist color filled in black and
white where the obviously without the
smoke it's not as interesting a picture
at all when you have this the the smoke
coming out of the airplane and it's
forming its own kind of
it was a very cold call day and it froze
those images in the smoke you know sort
of Sun in the sky
I love these images and off my work this
is some of the most unique I think any
artist that finds that a convenient
accident added to the aesthetic I just
love to do it again I'd love to do it
again but I can't know you already were
a photographer and a camera yeah and an
editor which are all of the talents and
experiences that you need to make a
picture like this you know I made a
living doing this in the early 80s and I
have thousands of images that I'm
revisiting now
it's getting me back to what I love I
love photography I love doing it and and
I'm I'm get a chance now to go through
multi decades of work I've got four
hundred thousand images so I'm just
beginning I'm gonna do multiple shows
and I'm so happy that people are
interested in it and I've got a great
foundation to support I mean you know
the Perry Cohen foundation Nick has
built this and I can I can help fund it
and we can help kids Perry's age it's
great you know there's a great tradition
of artists and galleries supporting
great causes do you also collect the tog
Rafi I do I do and you know that there
if it's photography in the last decade
has been one of the best asset classes I
own I've got a very eclectic collection
of work and every piece is unique I love
one of the kinds I love to find
something that no one else has I love
photography I just get lost in it I
spend you know I don't emerge for two
days out of my studio if you can
celebrate the work of others it also
encourages you and stimulates what you
do throughout life it's the coolest
thing it's a unique community of people
doing what they love to do I mean who
doesn't like this it's fantastic well
we're very pleased thanks a lot flattery
thank you that was a great tonight I'm
looking forward to it thanks
you